you'll hopefully see you become a mom oh
thank you I hope so too I really really
really hope so
well that's going to happen too sooner
than we thought because Real Housewives
of Orange County star Meghan King
Edmonds is pregnant
the 31 year old announced the exciting
news on Instagram with this pic she
captioned the shot we are thrilled to
bring our daughter into our perfectly
imperfect blended family in time for the
holidays this will be Megan's first
child with husband Jimmy Edmonds a
couple conceived to their daughter
through IVF baby baby baby baby baby
Meghan played coy about the pregnancy at
last week's Real Housewives of Orange
County premiere party but did open up to
et about her fertility journey after
going through this fertility journey I
realized that there's so many other
women out there who are going through
fertility issues on their own and so
it's been great to just kind of talk
about it and have that dialogue because
it's not an easy journey I just have to
ask is there anything to announce now is
there a baby on the way
you know IVF is really really difficult
and emotionally physically and I like to
think of IVF is not having an end but
really just having a next step